c'est au mois de janvier beaucoup de
morts malheureusement dans le domaine
culturel en france et notamment un grand
écrivain qui était michel tournier qui
vivait dans un presbytère dans les
yvelines
vous l'avez il avait été interviewé il
ya quelques années alors quand il était
encore en pleine forme
on va écouter puis on va parler de
culture avec mes prochains invités on
est chez moi parce que j'habite le
presbytère de choisel depuis 45 ans et j
ai écrit tout ce que j'ai publié et
c'est devenu une partie de moi-même
cette maison on se rend compte que vous
faites partie du patrimoine maintenant
et j'espère enfin pas trop parce que
chaque à côté un petit peu funèbre à
faire partie d'un patrimoine usant
provisoire est ce que vous imaginez
qu'un jour votre maison pour être le
lieu d'un inculte d'un pèlerinage
j'espère que non mais si c'était le cas
bien je c pas grave
toute façon un presbytère est une
méchante raisonnable et je les laissais
je n'y ai pas touché jeu léché tel quel
c'est odile auteur notamment du roi des
aulnes qui habitait ce presbytère dans
les yvelines alors on va parler de
culture maintenant avec avec vous
lyonnais masse et à qui devrait être de
50 ha avec sabine cossa qui dirigeait le
prisme et avec mark allemand graf qui
nous fait l'honneur le plaisir de nous
accueillir dans une de ses salles de
juger c'est peut-être un mot d'abord il
faut vraiment pas relayer le 13 novembre
donc été un évidement d'attentats
terroristes terrible dans une salade qui
était une salle de culture de spectacle
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que ça
a eu une conséquence alors non seulement
évidemment peut-être sur la peur d'un
certain de gens de venir dans des salles
le public mais peut-être dans vie et est
ce que est ce que vous avez ressenti un
contrecoup de ces attentats biennale
c'est à mes côtés il ya des vues
objectifs de la chose des vues plus
subjectif delà de la chose donc la peur
est une vue on va dire subjective dans
une réalité ainsi que dans les théâtres
privés dans les salles privées il ya une
baisse et les chiffres sont tombés de 30
% de la fréquentation par rapport à la
saison dernière dans les théâtres
publics et je pense notamment dans les
théâtres publics en dehors de paris
mais à paris je pense que ça à peu près
la même chose mais en dehors de paris
il ya une la baisse de fréquentation a
été beaucoup moins simple c'est assez
c'est assez
c'est d'ailleurs assez étonnant alors si
une très légère baisse de fréquentation
des personnes qui avaient acheté leur
place mais qui voit là n'ont pas n'ont
pas voulu venir mais qui reste assez
assez minime après on a mis en place des
mesures de sécurité à l'entrée des
théâtres à l'intérieur du théâtre de
façon d'une part à faire de la
prévention et d'autre part à rassurer
également les spectateurs pour dire que
l'on tenait compte de cette peur qui
pouvait avoir
il n'y a pas eu dans les théâtres
publics en tout cas la scène nationale
de véritables baisse je crois que
l'impact en revanche de deux de ces
attentats du 13 novembre est aussi une
réflexion qui a été induite par ces
attentats sur quel est le rôle des
théâtres publics des théâtres en général
et de la culture
voilà de la culture généralement et je
pense que ça nous ça nous pose une
véritable question sur le travail que
l'on fait et le sens que l'on met dans
le travail que l'on fait oui parce que
on l'a bouté je vous donne la parole
c'est vrai que c'était aussi des
attentats contre contre un art de vivre
est contre eux contre
d'une certaine façon notre culture
s'invite comme ça vous avez là que
j'avais envie d'ajouter quelque chose
par rapport à ce que viennent dire
lionel donc solitude et comportements
des gens mais ce qui est évident c'est
que les théâtres qui sont peut-être à
l'extérieur de paris il est un théâtre
de proximité on a beaucoup parlé de la
proximité sur la toute première partie
de votre émission patrice et donc tous
nos théâtres établissent un vrai lien
avec la population nous avons énormément
d'abonnés par exemple donc l'abonné via
une main d'oeuvre à trois fois et par
rapport à cette attaque sur une salle de
spectacle n'attaque de la culture de ce
qui peut unir les gens et de ces
phénomènes de partage de du vivre
ensemble qu'on a cité aussi précédemment
eh bien nous on a mangé en apprenne
clairement senti au prisme que d'abord
c'est et chez eux et qu'ils avaient
envie pas de le revendiquer mais voilà
ils étaient chez eux et on leur
enlèverait pas et je voudrais ajouter
juste quelque chose comme ça oui en leur
vrai pas non mais ça c'était très clair
on a discuté beaucoup avec les gens
avant le spectacle après les spectacles
et je suis intervenu parce que nous on a
été obligé d'annuler le 14 novembre
roberto fonseca le concert de roberto
fonseca ce pianiste cubain génialissime
et fatoumata diawara kate une malienne
et on la rejouer le 23 novembre parce
que d'abord roberto à tenait absolument
à se jouer parce qu'ils étaient à la
philharmonie de 13 et une fois qu'ils
ont eu fini de jouer à la philharmonie
ils ont découvert toute l'horreur au
stade de france mais toute cette horreur
que vous citiez tout à l'heure et alors
deux avant le concert j'ai donc pris la
parole et c'est vrai que j'ai dit une
chose qui était je pense enfin je pense
sincèrement c'est que l'éducation la
culture le développement de la pensée
sont sans aucun doute les armes les plus
puissantes pour défendre notre monde de
liberté moi je pense que nos spectateurs
ils en sont totalement conscients et
qu'ils y tiennent cois mark allemand
grave s vous allez sortir ou alors nous
c'est vrai qu'on a un double but
l'espèce et qu'on a une salle de
spectacles mais aussi dans un centre
commercial dont il ya un double impact
où les gens avaient peur d'aller dans
les centres commerciaux et ont plus à
l'est dans une salle de cinéma entre
autres
donc c'est vrai qu'on avait été fermée
le samedi comme beaucoup de salles et
comme beaucoup de centres commerciaux et
je sais que dès le dimanche j'ai voulu
absolument ouvrir
j'avais prévenu michel laugier que je
voulais ouvrir parce qu'on a vu en avant
première une équipe de films donc
l'équipe de films a décommandé mais je
voulais faire l'avant première pour
vraiment dire on est ouvert ce que c'est
un lieu symbolique que je voulais ouvrir
et les gens étaient là dès 9h30 du matin
je les ai accueillis à 9h30 du matin et
les gens sont venus en lisant on a
besoin de se changer les idées et
beaucoup de gens ne dit pas non plus
beaucoup mais il y avait un certain
nombre de gens qui nous ont remerciés
d'avoir fait l'effort de rester ouverts
malgré les craintes malgré y avait quand
même beaucoup d'incertitudes le dimanche
matin encore ils nous ont remerciés de
dire voilà vous c'est symbolique vous
est ouvert et c'est comme ça que moi je
les prie et après pour répondre à votre
question oui on a eu une baisse
significative de la clientèle notamment
sur la première semaine
contrairement à d'autres spectacles
comme le théâtre ou d'autres les gens
réservent nous ils peuvent me revenir
dans une semaine jour là il me vont
rester et heureusement qu'il y avait des
films forts notamment à star wars
quelques semaines après qui joue les
gens avaient une véritable envie de
ressortir de ressentir des émotions de
ressentir ben voilà on parler d'art de
vivre ont parié un certain nombre de
choses
ils sont revenus en masse rapidement au
mois de décembre
voilà on a eu une petite période de
latence où c'était plus compliqué là bas
dont je vais parler un petit peu de
théâtre mais mais après on va donner les
grands événements qui sont là en 2016
mais il ya une chose qui m'a toujours
fasciné que ce soit au théâtre de saint
quentin que ça soit au prisme c'est que
vous proposer des spectacles qui sont
des spectacles exigeants souvent et vous
arrivez à attirer une population ont
tous dit que c'est pas forcément la
première population qui est attiré par
la culture comme oh vous réussissez ce
pari absolument incroyable et presque
impossible c'est peut-être toute la
différence entre les théâtres publics et
des théâtres privés et c'est ce qui
justifie également les subventions
publiques que perçoivent
les théâtres comme la scène national de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est à dire que notre travail ne
consiste pas uniquement à programmer des
spectacles avec une grande diversité un
grand spectre voilà esthétique
artistique
il consiste aussi être sur le terrain
quotidiennement c'est à dire que dans le
travail de la scène nationale
il ya ce travail de programmation qui
représente alors je vais en faire
à la louche qui représente 50% de notre
travail les 50 autres pour cent de notre
travail c'est d'être sur le terrain en
permanence quand je dis nous c'est
l'équipe du théâtre de saint quentin
mais également les artistes c'est à dire
que ce sont les mêmes les artistes qui
sont sur scène et les artistes qui
interviennent dans les écoles mais
uniquement dans les écoles mais
également dans le milieu associatif dont
les structures sociales qui sont là pour
moi là pour porter cette parole pour
faire que l'on puisse parler sur un pied
d'égalité avec un artiste pour faire que
l'on vienne découvrir des oeuvres il y
avait été de 50,1 une représentation de
réparer les visant il mise en scène de
sylvain maurice du texte de maylis de
kerangal près leur mari il ya quelque
chose qui est à la fois réjouissant et
qui continue à me fascinait c'est qu'il
y avait sur les la petite salle sur les
300 personnes c'était archi plein sur
les 300 personnes il devait y avoir une
centaine de lycéens dont il ya cette
diversité générationnelle
il y avait un silence absolument
religieux c'est à dire que le but n'est
pas uniquement d'amener des populations
y compris des populations jeunes ont
parlé des poupées de populations
défavorisées dans le théâtre c'est faire
aussi en sorte qu'elle soit en capacité
de recevoir les oeuvres mustapha
larbaoui parlais tout à l'heure
en fait je me reconnaissais total 1
je reconnais c'est totalement le rôle
d'un théâtre public dans le discours que
qui tenait et cesser de parler des
lycéens mais c'est souvent les jeunes
qui amènent aussi leurs parents il ya un
système national de parents
accompagnateurs ça aussi c'est réussi
c'est à dire que tous les enfants qui
sont en projet avec avec la scène
nationale tous des projets musicaux des
projets théâtraux chorégraphique peuvent
amener leurs parents pour des tarifs
modiques ce qui fait que on retrouve
dans le théâtre
des parents accompagnateurs qui sont là
qui représente on va dire mille 1000
personnes chaque chaque saison à qui il
est possible d'avoir accès voilà à des
offres qu'elle soit certainement pas
naturellement venu voir bien sûr
sabine que ça c'est ce que vous a pas ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
qu'au fait les gens qui viennent ils ont
l'impression qu'ils sont chez eux quoi
que c'est leur maison oui voilà est un
projet comme celui du prisme qui sont de
développement artistique propose
énormément de rencontres la médiation
dont parlait lionel entre les artistes
et la population
on travaille beaucoup effectivement avec
les établissements scolaires et on
propose également des projets
participatifs au coeur duquel l artiste
et des habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines qui ont envie d'y participer
de la danse du théâtre mais le principe
est que quand on travaille par exemple
en milieu scolaire c'est l'enfant qui
est au coeur du projet c'est à dire que
du coup il ya une résidence d'artistes
dans l'établissement scolaire ça va
toucher dix classes c'est l'enfant qui
est au coeur parce que c'est grâce à son
enseignant il faut surtout pas l'oublier
la mobilisation des enseignants dans les
activités que l'on peut proposer avec
les artistes et l'enfant lui il va
revenir dans sa famille il va valoriser
son école par rapport à sa famille sa
femme elle va être valorisés par ce
qu'il fait puis il ya toujours des
restitutions des rencontres sur les
propos et à nous tel que le disent et
lionel lieu de vie lieu d'action
effectivement s'il ya dans des missions
qui nous sont confiées de l'argent
public qui nous est confiée c'est bien
pour qu'ils soient au plus large de la
population et dans sa diversité est bien
un parc à ce moment là à nous de
proposer comme des ateliers de danse aux
familles que le prisme effet le samedi
ces projets participatifs auquel je
faisais référence des conférences des
pianos bars tout ce qui va t-il ses
voitures et une relation je vais aller
plus loin je vis à vis de la culture et
de l'artiste merkel programme aise il ya
dans le cinéma il ya une action comme ça
qu'on peut faire les actions récurrentes
et est équipé que nous organisons je me
rappelle l'organisation du festival
qu'on avait lancé au mois de novembre où
il y avait une partie grand public il y
avait beaucoup de d'acteurs qui a été
associé et on avait une première le
vendredi on peut le vendredi toute une
journée dédiée aux scolaires
où de nombreux collégiens lycéens
étaient venus débattre avec des
producteurs ou des réalisateurs
on avait le projet un peu fou mais ça va
plus réalisé de faire une maison en
direct avec la base dumont d'urville
pour pouvoir échanger avec les
chercheurs là bas donc voilà c'est on
est toujours dans cette recherche
d'associer que ce soit des des jeunes
des moins jeunes on a aussi omar sy qui
avait invité un certain nombre de ses
amis de trappes où il y avait à peu près
une centaine d'invités dans la salle
dont il ya tout ce lien que ce soit avec
les jeunes que ce soit avec des milieux
un peu plus défavorisés que mon très
différemment d'une scène vivante ou
autre mais qu'on essaye de traduire tout
au long de l'année ayé un festival sur
les documentaires
il y aura une deuxième édition écoutez
on j'espère qu'il y aura une deuxième
tout est fait pour on va avoir une
première réunion dans les jours qui
viennent
en espèrant associés mais de mes deux
collègues qui sont à côté de moi pour
voilà reproduire quelque chose qui avait
fortement bien marché pour la première
soirée vu qu'on avait accueilli presque
500 personnes pour le film demain de
cyril dion d'ailleurs il avait débattu
avec le public on avait vu aussi
d'autres documentaires donc le but du
jeu c'est de pérenniser de faire rentrer
d'autres acteurs du territoire pour en
créer ce festival entièrement dans 51 en
yvelines alors assez vite parce que
valeureux voit l'auteur de presse les
grands événements dont vous attendez
beaucoup cette année on va commencer par
sabine comme ça on va aller vite comme
ça après je laisserai la parole à jamais
à mes collaborateurs mais qu'on mes
collègues pas peut-être
théâtre avec des grands thèmes vous
parlez des spectacles à venir
bon moi je vous ai parlé jusqu'à fin
2008 à juin 2016 puisque nous arrêtons
ces saisonniers dont on parle de
septembre à juin donc peut-être quelques
grands textes le novecento avait que du
seul lit ce livre a pris à bras le corps
donc c'est alessandro baricco qui a
écrit j'ai eu ce magnifique textes très
poétiques
ensuite un autre qui n'a absolument pas
dans le même registre est inconnu à
cette adresse de telle ray grass man
voilà et puis une fidélité avec un grand
monsieur de la dent jean claude gallotta
puisque voilà on est très lié
c'est un monsieur ce que j'appelle les
artistes de l'altérité c'est les
artistes ouvert aux autres très
attentifs ne s'enfermant pas ayant
besoin de se nourrir au contact des
autres
donc il est mon et la ville fascinée par
l'étranger d'albert camus
oui voilà et oui une danse en l'étranger
qui sera un bon moment aussi pur finir
par un un petit coup de coeur des
découvertes bien que pour nous elle soit
déjà connu mais est une très belle femme
du désert marocain et qui chante dans la
tradition mais qui du coup c'est
beaucoup plus ouverte aux sonorités du
jazz aux sonorités des caraïbes de la
musique cubaine et nous fait un mixage
toutes les cultures et donne vraiment
avait un concert d'une grande générosité
il y en a une c'est à moi j'ai toujours
beaucoup de mal à faire déjouer
bien sûr elles seront les temps forts je
pense que la saison est aussi outré
saison efforts et puis lens et surtout
que la saison est conçu comme un comme
un parcours sur différents différentes
possibilités de parcours pour le
spectateur
non je parlerai de 2,2 deux oeuvres qui
vont être qu'ils vont être joué dans pas
très longtemps au mois de février à
saint quentin la première c'est le je
crois que c'est le 19 février la petite
renarde rusée voilà en parler de
d'initiation à la culture la petite
renarde rusée une oeuvre de janacek qui
je pense a dû être composée au 12
alentours de 2900 1920 une un briquet
d'une immense richesse une grande
diversité qui a été mise en scène par
une jeune metteur en scène qui s'appelle
louise moaty avec tout en tout un
travail
visuel de dessin d'incrustations qui
sont faites en direct et c'est
typiquement le genre d'oeuvre d'une part
oeuvre remarquable remarquablement
interprétée et mise en scène qui sont un
régal pour les yeux et pour les oreilles
et où on peut amener des jeunes
spectateurs à découvrir l'opéra voilà ça
c'est à découvrir
je pourrais parler également d'une d'une
pièce aller un texte qui a été écrit à
peu près vers la même heure même époque
ans à notre en 1920 1910 par claudel
c'est l'annoncé faite à marie
comme quoi le rôle du théâtre c'est
aussi d'actualiser d'établir julian qui
ont un peu plus un peu plus d'un siècle
et parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
les découvrent aussi cette gens qui les
découvrent et surtout de les faire
découvrir de façon à faire déférer donc
ce texte qui est ce qu'on appelle un
mystère c'est à dire qu'il ya quelque
chose de très mystique dont sedan ce
travail comme dans toute l'écriture de
paul claudel a été réadaptée par yves
beaunesne metteur en scène qui en a fait
une oeuvre quasiment musical où on va
dire que la musicalité du verbe
claudélien voilà voisine à côté de la
musicalité d'aider des oeuvres de
camille d'un jeune compositeur
compositeur qui s'appelle camille
rocailleux
voilà aussi deux façons d'aller vers une
culture on va dire classique une culture
de répertoire qui est remise au goût du
jour ces deux très belles occasions de
découvrir ses oeuvres la voilà je dirais
pas aller plus loin que je voulais
ajouter une petite chose importante
c'est lionel masse et a cité deux
metteurs en scène ou metteur en scène
c'est important nous pressons essaye de
s'attacher à l'oral à paris on essaye de
s'inscrire dans les parités saison une
femme on n'y arrive pas à mettre 50 %
d'hommes 50 % de femmes en plus ces
dérangements franchement qui sont d'un
très très pratique mais par contre
soutenir des projets de femmes de
production au féminin pour essayer de
remonter un peu cet équilibre assez
juste cette petite 1,6 que je voulais
faire qui n'est pas pour les défendre
qui juste valoriser la marque allemande
nous c'est vrai qu'on a une activité
très riche tout au long de l'année 1 je
vois dans la semaine prochaine on va
recevoir l'équipe de films de joséphine
s'arrondit avec marilou berry
on essaye de redévelopper de re faire
revenir beaucoup d'acteurs la de la
korité de la semaine dernière on avait
omar sy et tout fin décembre on avait
josiane balasko qui sont venus ici donc
c'est vrai qu'on a une activité assez
riche avec naturellement tous les
groupes poster américain qu'on connaît
j'épouse la liste par contre c'est vrai
que là tout début février le onze on a
le trouvère qu'on va diffuser en direct
la bastille et c'est vrai qu'on parlait
des jeunes aussi et on remarque de plus
en plus de jeunes qui viennent ouadhias
initiés je sais pas si c'est initier ou
découvrir sur les opéras et notamment
une proportion importante sur les balais
je pense que les jeunes sont peut-être
plus où les jeunes filles peut-être plus
attentifs aux balais mais sinon voilà on
a une actualité très riche et puis il ya
les vacances scolaires qui arrivent et
avec des choses un peu plus exotiques
comme on aura l'équipe de pattaya donc
ça c'est nettement plus exotique on va
dire sûrement avec d'allemagne à gad
elmaleh ou autres voilà non une activité
très riche tout au long de l'année et
des gros blockbusters qui vont gâcher
attire naturellement et on finira sur la
fin de l'année va un spin off de star
wars qui sera un rogue leader ou là là
aussi on raconte qu'ils vont continuer
jusqu'à 2020 un épisode où un spin off
de star wars pour ponctuer jusqu'à 2020
donc voilà on a de l'actualité est riche
qui nous attend toute la doc voilà bah
y'a de quoi venir au théâtre venir au
cinéma merci merci à tous les trois et
j'ai envie de vous dire aussi bravo
parce que ce que vous faites est
absolument formidable